so Anthony you have an experience
actually under the bridge from what I
read you felt alienated you felt alone
and you said to yourself oh God this is
the feeling of loneliness and it's
horrible and you actually said the
lyrics to yourself is that is is that
correct is that how it worked
um I had certainly alienated myself from
the rest of
the world and then I wrote a little poem
to myself which was on the very last
page of my notebook and sitting with
Rick Rubin he's like what else you got
what else you got and I'm like that's
really all I got and he's like what's
this poem on the back page and I'm like
Ah that's personal
How does it go so I sang it to him and
he said that's a song and you didn't
think it was good enough to bring to the
band because it's too personal and Rick
says to you what the [__] do this hey I
didn't have the entire song worked out
and and be the the whole Melody changed
when John put
guitar chords beneath it or next to it
or on top of it
um it it brought something
to the song that the song didn't have
and it was just acapella
it was different it was personal we
hadn't really gone down that road yet
but the cool thing was that when I sang
it to anybody in the band they were like
oh hell yes that's let's work on that I
was like you sure all right we ready to
do this we're gonna go back in time now
under the bridge and the Red Hot Chili
Peppers doing it live
[Music]
sometimes I feel like I don't have a
partner
sometimes I feel like my only friend is
the city I live in the City of Angels
lonely as I am together we cry
foreign
[Music]
I drive on the streets cause she's my
companion I'll walk through a hill cause
she knows who I am she sees my 50th and
she kissed his new one day but I never
worry now that is alive
hmm
[Music]
I love
me
[Applause]
[Music]
take me off your way
it's hard to believe that there's nobody
out there hard to believe
that I'm all alone
at least I have heard love the status
should love me
loneliest I am together we cry
please
[Music]
I love
you I don't ever wanna be
like I did it take me to the place I
loved
[Music]
me
fears
[Music]
foreign
that's good